mid-afternoon at a busy shopping mall in
Texas and dash cam video shows a man
step out of a car and start shooting
passers-by
What followed was the latest mass
shooting in a country divided over gun
violence Witnesses ran for cover we see
the guy there's a sky dressing all black
wearing a vest has an assault rifle and
he's just shooting at people
right across he was at like Francesca's
area shooting at people so we got
everyone in the store in the back of the
store and just camped out there
and then we just took her to the back uh
there was that people on the floor a lot
of people they were like you know hiding
and as I was going around they told me
to get away you know to move out and I
kept on telling them I'm looking for my
daughter police evacuated hundreds of
Shoppers from the mall in Allen just
north of Dallas the gunman was killed by
an officer who happened to be nearby the
motive is still unknown at 3 36 our
officer was at Allen Premium Outlets on
an unrelated call
he heard gunshots located The Gunshot
located the shooter neutralized the
shooter neutralized the threat we
believe at this point that the shooter
acted alone barely a week ago a man in
Cleveland Texas killed five of his
neighbor's most adults aged 21 or over
in the state are allowed to carry a
handgun without a license the city of
Allen is now in shock we are a strong
and caring community and we all want the
victims and their families impacted by
this tragedy to know that we will wrap
our arms around you and we are here for
you this is the 199th mass shooting in
the United States this year that has
left four or more people dead or wounded
according to the gun violence archive
once again a community is in mourning
Thomas More Sky News